I just want to recap what
I talked about last time.
Very briefly,
I made the point in the first lecture
that American literature in the middle of
the 20th century is
particularly preoccupied with
the relationship between the
writer and the reader,
between imagination and lived experience
between fiction and truth between the
reader and the text,
that these are very vexed and
contested interfaces at this period.
I also made the argument
that at this moment,
literary art is struggling with what to
do with the legacy of modernism in the
early century,
but there's another strain from the
early century that matters and matters,
particularly to Richard Wright.
And that is the American
strain of naturalism.
A writer's like Theodore Dreiser,
right?
His writing very much in
the vein of those writers.
So even though he's very closely
connected to the legacy of avant garde
modernism,
he's also connected to
a social realist strain,
the naturalist strain.
Those are two slightly different things,
which I won't go into right now.
Um,
he's connected to both those strains
as well as the modernist, uh,
strain.
So what I want to do today is look
closely first at the selections from black
boy that I asked you to read.
Uh,
and to look at those as a text and to ask
ourselves what we can learn about what
kind of story it is.
And I said about that problem.
Is it autobiography? Is it
fiction? What's it trying to do?
What kind of reader does it want?
Um,
I suggested that there was a critical
response to those issues that was somewhat
negative.
And I want to sort of remind you of that
just by reading you a little bit from
Web Dubois is review of
black boy when it came out.
Um, I think this sums up nicely what
I was trying to communicate last time.
He says,
this book tells a harsh and forbidding
story and makes one wonder just exactly
what its relation to truth is the
title a record of childhood and youth.
That was the subtitle makes one first
think that the story is autobiographical.
It probably is at least in part,
but mainly it is probably intended to
be fiction or fictionalized biography.
At any rate,
the reader must regard it as creative
writing rather than simply a record of
life.
So that's still B e B Dubois.
And I'm going to to take his advice and
now begin to read this book with you as
creative writing. So let's see what it
says to us when we look at it that way.
I want to start, I'm going to read, uh,
passages quite a bit today since some
of you may not have been able to get the
Ras packet in time,
it being shopping period.
So I'm going to read passages and I hope
you'll jump around with me if you have
the texts in your hand. Um, in general,
you should always bring the book to class.
This is on page 267.
This is from that second half of the
book that was not published originally,
but I want to point to it.
First of all,
in raising the question,
what did we lose
in understanding this as a literary
object when the second half of the book,
you can come in and sit down if you want.
There's some space down here.
Um,
what did we lose in our understanding of
it as a literary object when the second
half was not published?
There are some seats here too
on two 67.
This is in one of these parent
thetical passages where the narrator is
commenting on what he's just,
um,
give an account of in his experience.
Slowly I began to forge
in the depths of my mind.
This is the very top of the page,
a mechanism that repressed all the dreams
and desires that the Chicago streets,
the newspapers,
the movies were evoking in me.
I was going through a second childhood,
a new sense of the limit of the
possible was being born in me.
What right?
Gives us.
Here is an account of the two parts of
this story that says this is an account
of not one childhood,
but too.
So one thing that readers lost when they
lost the second half of this book is
the sense that maturing the process
process of maturing was more than just the
process of leaving the south
that has a typical buildings,
Roman structure,
the structure of a story about a boy
who goes out from his home and sort of
becomes a man through his travels.
If you just have the first half,
you think that that development is
accomplished when Richard decides to leave
the south.
But what he tells us very
early in part two is no,
it takes two childhoods for a
black man to make that journey.
So what is that journey then that
required two childhoods to accomplish a
childhood in the south and
then a childhood in the north.
So now I want to turn to
the beginning of the book.
I'm on page seven.
I'm also gonna do some
summarizing of these scenes. Um,
if for people who haven't read, um, make
yourselves as comfortable as you can.
As I mentioned last time in
the first scene of this book,
the Child Richard Burns down his family's
house playing with matches underneath
the curtains. His mother, uh,
he goes and hides under the house afraid
of the beating his mother will give him
and indeed when his mother
finally finds him, uh,
he is beaten unconscious
and he is feverish and sick
for a long time afterward.
And what I want to read to you
is this passage on page seven,
I was lost in a fog of fear.
A doctor was called,
I was afterwards told and he ordered that
I be kept a bed, that I be kept quiet,
that very,
my very life depended upon it.
My body seemed on fire
and I could not sleep.
Packs of ice were put on my
forehead to keep down the fever,
whatever I tried to sleep,
I would see huge wobbley white bags
like the full auditors of cows suspended
from the ceiling above me.
Later. As I grew worse,
I could see the bags in the daytime with
my eyes open and I was gripped by the
fear that they were going to fall and
drench me with some horrible liquid day
and night. I begged my mother
and father to take the bags away,
pointing to them shaking with terror
because no one saw them but me.
Exhaustion would make me drift towards
sleep and then I would scream until I was
wide awake again.
I was afraid to sleep.
Time finally bore me away from
the dangerous bags and I got well,
but for a long time I was chastened
whenever I remembered that my mother had
come close to killing me.
Why start with this scene?
I said last time that part of the art
of autobiography is choosing what do you
choose out of your life? Where
do you begin? Where do you end?
What do you put next to?
What?
Why does right choose this scene?
It's very dramatic,
so it has that going for it.
It's a hook.
I would suggest that this little passage
I just read to you tells us in part
why.
Yeah,
it's a moment when a child realizes that
the person who gave him life can revoke
it.
His mother who gave him life can
take that life away from him.
It's a profound sense of jeopardy.
Physical,
mortal,
jeopardy and I want to point to those
huge wobbly white bags like the full
utters of cows.
One of the wonderful things you
can see in the buying of keys,
Richard Wright archives,
is the draft copies of black boy,
right?
Revised this image in those drafts.
It was at one time white faces,
not white bags,
white faces.
This to me is a fascinating revision.
First of all,
it suggests of course that he
was giving language to something,
making a specific image out of something
that didn't quite have that specific
content in his experience as a child,
but that revision is also a way from a
sense that this jeopardy is represented
by a racial face,
the symbolic face of black oppression,
the white face that is always cruelly set
against the black boy of this account.
He revises it away from that to the more
generalized fundamental but also very
personal figure of the
mother and the maternal.
So the white bags, this is an image
of the breast. We have the, um,
this fear of the horrible
white liquid as if milk,
we're going to drown him.
So the threat embodied by the mother who
will beat her own son on conscious is
embodied in that fevered vision of
the bags like the full utters of cows.
Yeah.
So this novel,
this autobiography begins with the
sense that this boy is in danger from
practically the moment
he comes into the world.
The moment he comes into consciousness
that I want to note the transition that
happens at the very bottom of this page
after he says,
I was chasing,
whenever I remembered that my
mother had come close to killing me,
then we move into something
that I call a catalog.
There are three of these
in the first half. Um,
it's a list of sensations or perceptions
that don't have a particular narrative
structure. Exactly. They're just a sort of
of experience.
Each event spoke with a cryptic tone and
the moments of living slowly revealed
they're coded meanings.
There was the wonder,
I felt when I saw of brace like mountain
abrasive mountain likes spotted black
and white horses clopping down a dusty
road through clouds of powdered clay.
There was the delight I caught in seeing
long straight rows of red and green
vegetables stretching away in
the sun to the bright horizon.
There was the fate,
cool kiss of sensuality when
do came to my cheeks and shins.
As I ran down the wet green
garden paths in the early morning,
there was the vague sense of the infinite.
As I looked down upon the yellow dreaming
waters of the Mississippi from the
Verdun bluffs of Nachos,
I'm going to stop there.
There's a lot you can
say about these catalogs.
And when I used to teach the whole of
this text over a course of two days, um,
I would spend a lot of time and if you
want to it's worth and it repays the time
that you could spend rereading these
and thinking about the exact language.
For instance here at the very top of page
eight when he talks about the dreaming
waters of the Mississippi River,
what you have there is a moment when
the perception of the child becomes the
perception of the world
imbued with imagination.
So the river is not dreaming,
it's Richard Who's dreaming.
So this is in part a catalog that
represents the weakening of sensuality,
the awakening of the body to its
environment, to his environment.
But also there's this sense of imagination
and you get that in the dreaming
waters.
You get that in the sense of travel or
the image of the road that you can see in
the green and red vegetables stretching
away in their rose to the bright
horizon. There's that sense
of, of space, of expansiveness,
the possibility of travel.
Why put this next to right
after that very dramatic scene?
Why is this the moment to enter
into that meditation? Well,
I think it's because it's in bonding,
an oscillation that we'll come back in
this text between radical jeopardy and
deprivation and the
compensation of sensuality,
emotion and imagination.
These to oscillate back and forth.
So the moment of deprivation is often
then balanced by a moment of imagination.
Yeah,
and so what I'm going to do just now
run through the next two or three scenes
and talk about why they're
set next to each other.
So the next one we have a just on
page nine is come quite rapidly.
Here
is the day his mother tells him that
they're going to Memphis on a boat called
the Kate Adams. He said, he says,
my eagerness thereafter
made the days seem endless.
Each night I went to bed hoping that
the next morning would be the day of
departure. How big is the boat? I
asked my mother as big as a mountain.
She said, how's it got a whistle?
Yes. Just the whistle blow.
Yes. When? When the
captain wants it to blow.
Why do they call it the Kate Adams?
Because that's the boat's name.
What color is the boat? White.
How long will we be on the boat?
All Day and all night while we sleep
on the boat? Yes. When we get sleep,
he will sleep now hush.
For days,
I had dreamed about a huge white boat
floating on a vast body of water.
But when my mother took me down
to the levy on the day of leaving,
I saw a tiny dirty boat that was not
at all like the boat I had imagined.
If in the catalog,
imagination is awakened,
this is what it can then do.
For Richard.
It can endow his daily experience
with a kind of romance.
But of course,
this is a poor black child growing
up in the south and his expectations,
what his mind can imagine is always going
to be greater than what the world can
deliver.
So if the landscape invites him
to grow as an imaginative person,
the social world, he lives in this
episode signals to us immediately.
We'll never live up to that imagination.
Yeah.
There is a sense of powerlessness that
arises from the repeated oscillation that
you start to see even set up in
these first three little vignettes.
And the problem of powerlessness is first
located not centrally in that social
world. I don't think we're meant to
understand that the young Richard,
when he discovers that the Kate Adams
is a dirty little boat and not this
romantic vision of a ship,
he had hoped for that the young
Richard thinks to himself.
This is because I am a poor black
boy growing up in the south.
It's simply an experience
of disappointment,
the sense of powerlessness,
the most profound sense of powerlessness
suggested already by the first episode
where his mother almost takes back
the life she gave him is rooted in the
family.
And we get such a dramatic vision of
that in the next episode that follows the
episode of the kitten.
So for those of you who haven't read,
Richard's Father Works Nights
and sleeps during the day and uh,
during the day the children
therefore have to be very quiet.
There is a cat outside the apartment
building that starts to meow and the boys
are interested in it. The
father yells at them, says,
make that catch shot up and they can't.
He says,
make it shut up.
I don't care half kill it if
you have to kill that cat.
Richard at this point
already hates his father.
His father will abandon the family quite
soon after this episode for Richard.
He is mostly this kind of presence,
a Cavaillon,
angry,
abusive presence.
His resentment over his powerlessness
within the family seeds in this moment,
and he thinks of a way to
get back at his father.
I'll take his words,
literally, I will kill the cat.
He thinks that's how he does.
He hangs the cat.
Richard's mother finds out
when his brother tells on him
and the father cannot punish him.
He has taken the father's words literally
when they were not meant literally.
But in doing so, in relying on
his father's words in a sense,
to protect him,
even as he subverts them,
he escapes the punishment that would
otherwise so naturally and habitually
follow.
So Richard's first exertion of agency
in this book is through the Agency of
words in this case,
in asserting an interpretation of the
words at odds with their intended meaning.
It's as if Richard takes those
words and he makes them his own,
takes them from his father and gains a
different kind of strength from them,
a strength he can then use
to get back at his father.
This was the first instance in which
Richard will do what he later describes
Mankin doing,
using as weapons.
His discovery of Mankin using words as
weapons in a political sense is a very
powerful moment for him in his
intellectual development. In this case,
it's a much more visceral
kind of development.
It's the understanding that he can
make things happen in the world.
He can defend himself against his father's
punishment through the use of words,
but I want to note
that his mother takes
a different approach.
If his father resigns himself
to Richard a subterfuge,
his mother does not, and
this is on page 12 he says,
I had had my first triumph over my father.
I had made him believe that I
had taken his words literally.
He could not punish me now
without risking his authority.
I was happy because I had at last found
a way to throw my criticism of him into
his face. I had made him feel that if
he whipped me for killing the kitten,
I would never give serious
weight to his words again.
I had made him know that I felt he was
cruel and I had done it without his
punishing me.
But my mother being more imaginative,
retaliated with an assault
upon my sensibilities that
crushed me with the moral
horror involved in taking a life.
And I want to just flip over to 13
about the same place on the page she's
confronted him with having knowingly
taken the father's words the wrong way.
Uh, you stop that lying. You knew
what he meant. I didn't eyeballed.
She shoved a tiny spade into my hands.
Go out there and dig a
hole and bury that kitten.
I stumbled out into the Black Knights
sobbing my legs wobbly from fear though I
knew that I had killed the kitten.
My mother's words had made it live again.
In my mind, what would that
kitten do to me when I touched it?
Would it caught my eyes as I grew up
toward the dead kid and my mother lingered
behind me, unseen in the dark, her
disembodied voice egging me on.
The mother has her own way
of using words for power
and she does it by making the kitten
live again in his imagination.
It's as if she's writing
fiction there in that scene,
she is representing this kitten that he's
killed so that it comes back to haunt
him.
So once again,
there's that immediate oscillation.
The moment Richard gain some
power from the use of words,
his mother takes it back by
exerting that power herself,
taking that power away from him.
There's a kind of drum beat
of a thematic material.
As these scenes pile up,
the drum beat is all about language.
Yes,
this is a book about the privations
of growing up in the south,
poor and black,
but it is very much very consciously a
book about the development of someone who
attends to language.
So in these early scenes,
it's all about power,
but it's actually not even quite so easy
or so simple as these early scenes that
I've just discussed
might make out language,
has powers that are
entirely unpredictable,
that can't be harnessed in precisely that
deliberate way by making a decision to
take someone's words in the wrong way
or by telling a story to make a moral
point as the mother does.
So think about the scene
where Richard gets, uh,
drinks in the saloon as a child.
Patrons pay him and give him drinks to
go up and repeat their words to other
people in the bar. Usually this
happens between men and women.
So a man will give Richard a drink and
pay him a few pennies to go to a woman in
the bar and repeat certain things
that he has a trained Richard to say,
okay,
in doing this,
the patrons tit her,
everybody sort of has fun with this.
Richard has no idea what he's saying.
He's simply repeating the sounds
of the words that are given to him
through this process.
He becomes addicted to
alcohol at a very young age.
But at the same time,
he learns something about language.
It has mysterious powers.
It has capacities to make things happen
in the world that he doesn't know how to
control.
Okay.
When he finally emerges from this
time of being a young drunkard,
his mother sort of locks him up in the
house and make sure he can't get out and
then take some to work with her and
so on so that he loses that taste for
alcohol in the tax.
What you have right next to that is the
beginning of his insatiable questions.
He starts just torture his mother with
a thousand questions about everything in
the world.
The addiction to alcohol is in a sense
replaced by an addiction to knowledge.
The experience of having language
speak through him and do things that he
doesn't understand
makes him want to again,
that agency that he experienced when
he took his father's words. Literally
this
theme comes back in the
scene where his grandmother,
his washing him, you remember
the scene, his grandmother,
his washing him and his brother in the
tub and she's washing his butt and he
says to her,
when you're finished,
kiss back there and woo,
she's flying off the roof with anger,
chasing him around the house,
trying to whip him with a wet towel.
So on and so forth.
Very dramatic scene again of powerlessness
within the family of being the victim
of violence within the family.
But in this case,
it's a response produced
in the negative register,
similar to the responses
produced in the saloon.
He says something and he doesn't really
know where those words come from.
He doesn't really know what made his
granny so angry about those words.
He doesn't understand
the words that he's used,
but boy do they produce a response.
So there's this sense in which the story
of a developing writer is the story of
someone learning even before they
learn how to control language fully.
That language has these capacities.
Well,
there's another element though to
the kind of language that Richard is
describing learning and that
is the racial element element.
He is learning a racialized language.
And here I want to look
at page. Uh, let's see,
page 79
actually first on 47
just in passing quickly.
You know what I'm looking at my watch,
we don't have time.
We'll go straight to 79.
On page 79 we get an account
of a conversation between
Richard and his friends
and it's annotated
with interpretive asides.
So I'm going to start in
the middle of this. Um,
the crowd laughs long and loud.
This in the middle of the page, man.
Then white folks ought to catch you and
send you to a zoo and keep you for the
next war,
throwing the subject into a wider field.
Then when that fighting starts,
they ought to feed you on buttermilk and
black eyed peas and let you break wind.
The subject is accepted and extended.
You'd win the war with a new kind
of poison gas. I shouted. Climax.
There's high laughter that simmers
down slowly may be poisoned gases,
something good to have. The subject
of white folks is associational.
He swept into the orbit of talk.
Yeah.
If they have a race ride around here,
I'm going to kill all the white
folks with my poison bit. Her pride,
gleeful laughter.
Then silence each waiting for the other
to contribute something than white folks.
Sure. Scared of us though. Sober
statement of an old problem.
What we see here is a doubled voice.
This is a moment when the narrative
voice begins to split in a very conscious
way.
So what you have is the account of Richard
and his friends talking in the past
and you have the present narrators
parsing of how this language relates to
topics that impinge upon
their very, uh, context,
the racial realities of the south.
So what you see here is a narrator
who has learned to do that,
parsing some of these terms that he uses,
our literary climax,
the creation of suspense.
So he's tracking this as if it were
the development of a narrative,
but he's also suggesting how humor is
used to broach topics that are impossible
to talk about in more direct ways or
that feel dangerous to these boys to
approach in more direct ways.
So there is a kind of grammar of race
that this boy is learning while he
experiences language in
all these other more um,
visceral family oriented ways.
There's the social context
of race relations, who's
grammar he is also learning.
And I would just remind you of the
passage where he starts to ask his mother
about whether his granny is white or not.
There's a long conversation and
she gets very frustrated with him.
She doesn't really want
to answer that question.
She is a woman who looks very white but
is categorized as black in that system
of the south.
And so Richard is learning a grammar of
race even while he tries to work out how
to use language as a source
of power in his family.
The split voice,
the development of what you could say
is that racial double consciousness.
The WB Dubois talks about
that double consciousness of the racial
reality is manifested in that split in
the narrative,
in the horror and the glory.
The second half of the
book as originally written,
that voice becomes the parent thetical.
It takes another development altogether.
So if you look in certain passages,
um,
let's see,
on two 72 and two 73.
Okay.
Actually I'm going to start to 71.
Um,
this is where Richard is
talking about the waitresses,
the white waitresses he works with
and the restaurant in Chicago.
This is what he says about them.
Um,
about three quarters of the way
down the page during my lunch hour,
which I spent on a bench in a nearby park,
the waitresses would come and sit beside
me talking at random, laughing, joking,
smoking cigarettes. I learned about their
tawdry dreams. There's simple hopes.
Their home lives, their fear of feeling
anything deeply, their sex problems,
their husbands, they were an eager,
restless, talkative, ignorant bunch,
but casually, kind and impersonal for
all that they knew nothing of hate.
And fear and strove instinctively
to avoid all passion.
That commentary that you get right in
the scene, not in the parent theoretical.
It's as if the Voice of
Richard remembering the
early parts of his childhood,
the voice that can parse a conversation
is then part of what gets remembered as
part of the scene.
When Richard is with those waitresses,
he's reflecting on these
things as he experiences them,
but there's a second kind
of development in this,
gets to that second childhood he invokes
that happens to him when he goes to
Chicago.
There's a social analysis that
he begins to be able to advance,
partly due to his reading
and Marxism in sociology.
Right,
was very interested in the sociology of
the 1930s and forties he read a lot in
that vein.
He was very interested in economics and
he wanted to understand how the social
structures of capitalism and the economic
structures of capitalism impinged upon
the way personalities were formed and
that's why he's interested in the emotions
of these waitresses and in fact the
question of emotion bears directly on his
sense of what books are for.
There's a remarkable moment on page 280
where he talks about his aspiration as a
writer,
and this is remarkable for how different
it is from someone like no back off or
John Barth or many of our
other writers on the syllabus.
If I could fasten the mind of the reader
upon words so firmly that he would
forget words and be conscious
only of his response,
I felt that I would be insight of
knowing how to write narrative.
I strove to master words
to make them disappear,
to make them important,
by making them new,
to make them melt into a rising spiral
of emotional stimuli each greater than
the other,
each feeding and reinforcing the other
and all ending an emotional climax that
would drench the reader
with a sense of a new world.
That was the single aim of my living.
That's remarkable for a writer to say,
I want to write so that
my words disappear.
Yeah.
He doesn't want us to see
the art of his sentences.
He wants us to feel and it is in fact
feeling that he credits two novels
that allows him to imagine that he
himself could have a different life and he
talks about this.
If you look at the published ending on
four 13 that we find in the notes when
this second half wasn't there,
when he asks,
how dare I consider my feeling superior
to the gross environment that sought to
claim me,
he states the problem of living in
the south as a problem of feeling
that he needed to claim and
consider his own feelings.
He says it had only been
through books at best,
no more than vicarious
cultural transfusions that
I had managed to keep myself
alive in a negatively vital way.
My belief in books had arisen more out
of a sense of desperation than from my
abiding conviction of their ultimate
value and I'm just going to skip down.
It had all,
it had been my accidental reading of
fiction and literary criticism that had
invoked in me vague glimpses
of life's possibilities.
Reading for him is a way
of accessing feeling.
And that's the kind of
reading that he wants from us,
from the people who read his book.
The kind of feeling that he wants us to
have is sort of stated in that alternate
ending.
But the horror and the glory shows how
that kind of feeling enters into a much
larger cultural analysis.
That piece of it,
which is gone when the
second half disappears.
That piece of it is what he tries to
communicate in a very condensed way.
And I want now to show you some of
those letters that I mentioned. Andrew,
can you get this screen in the lights?
Um,
I'm switching gears pretty quickly here
because we don't have a lot of time.
As I explained last time,
it was the book of the month club that,
um,
that caused him to make
this change in his account.
And what I have in front of you right now
is the second page of the first letter
that Dorothy Canfield Fisher wrote to
right where she first raises the problem
that she sees in, uh, the ending
as he has revised it. Now,
the shame here is that she's talking
about a version of the ending.
You see in that note on
four 13 in our edition,
she's talking about an early draft of
that ending and it's not in the buying of
key. Um, I don't know where it is.
I don't know where the
drafts that accompanied these
correspondences are. Now.
It's just possible that there in that
big archives somewhere and I just haven't
found them yet. Um, so if any of you want
to be an archive sleuth and find them,
great. I looked and I can't find them.
Sometimes when correspondence is saved,
you run into these kinds of problems.
Um,
so we have to guess a little bit
at what she was looking at. Um,
what are, what, uh,
what I want to point out to you is this,
um,
this part of her letter, the
third paragraph here where
she says, my idea is this,
in the first part of the letter she has,
um,
she's made some sentence level suggestions
for the end of the book and now she
embarks very tentatively
on her major suggestion.
My idea is this.
You ask a question,
all of your many readers have asked
themselves about you with an eagerness,
full of anxious hope.
What was it that always
made me feel that way?
What was it that made me conscious of
possibilities from where had I caught a
sense of freedom? And if you've
read the ending in the notes,
you'll remember though those
passages where he asks that question,
and his answer in, in that published
version is, uh, is from books.
But this is what she's thinking.
We to ask ourselves that question,
we meaning those Americans who following
the example of their parents and
grandparents have done what they could
to lighten this dark stain of racial
discrimination in our nation.
What we have hoped Finkley hoped was that
those efforts of men of goodwill have
somewhat availed a little enough so that
those suffering from racial injustice
might catch a passing glimpse of the fact
that they are rooted in those American
principles.
So mocked and degraded by the practices
of racial discrimination in what else
could they be rooted that they exist is
a proof that American ideals are not the
tawdry pretenses.
They are so often accused of being
a, and then I'm going to skip down
to the bottom of the next paragraph.
To keep conception in regard
to decent race relations,
alive and growing has been the aspiration
of generation after generation in many
in American family,
judging by my own and by those I know
to receive in the closing pages of your
book, one word of recognition
for this aspiration,
if it were possible for you
to give such recognition,
honestly would harden all who
believe in American ideals.
This is quite striking.
Imagine that you are Richard Wright and
you've grown up with the life that he
describes in this book.
Now you've read some of it and you're
being asked to suggest in the closing
pages of the novel of the autobiography,
which is closing where you did not want
it to close in the middle of your book,
not at the end of your book.
You're being asked to essentially think
the good liberal white people who have
been working on behalf of the
end of racial discrimination.
Yeah,
well, right. Finds this
an extremely difficult,
uh, request to respond
to. And you can track it
here in his response.
I'm going to read from here
so I can actually see it.
You more general. He says, okay, I'll
respond to those sentence level things.
You're more general suggestion
was much harder to deal with.
I fully understand the value
of what you're driving at,
but frankly the narrative as it now
stands simply will not support a more
general or hopeful conclusion.
The Negro who flees the
south is really a refugee.
He is so pinched and straightened in his
environment that is leaving is more and
avoidance than an embrace.
For me.
It has been my reading of fiction far
removed from political considerations that
evoked in me a sense of personal freedom
or the possibilities of escaping the
south.
I added a paragraph to the body of the
epilogue expanding this notion and I take
that to be the paragraph where he,
uh,
he talks about what fiction
has done for him specifically.
Yeah.
Canfield Fisher is not
satisfied with this.
She
comes back at the problem.
This is at the bottom of the letter.
I gather that you cannot bring yourself
to use even once the word American in
speaking of the tinge of warmth,
which came from an unseen light,
such a beautiful,
sensitive phrase.
Some of the novels and you read were it
is pop probable laid in your own country
of America.
Hence some of the characters in books
through whom you had glimpsed life's
possibilities.
We're fellow Americans of yours.
These unseen lights which shown
through them upon your faith, uh,
upon your faith were reflections of
American efforts to live up to an idea.
Those characters could have been no other
than products of American tradition.
However,
dimly that light came through to you
suffering so acutely from the rough denial
of the very existence of American ideal,
part of it must've come through American
delineation of American characters.
Now keep in mind, this is 1944.
This is the summer of 1944.
America is just joining
the war effort in Europe.
This is a fight against fascism.
That's the way that it was presented
to the American public, uh,
fight against Nazi Germany.
And in later letters in this
series between her and Richard. Um,
and also in the review,
the little sort of, um,
summary that she wrote up for the
book of the month club newsletter,
she invokes the Nazis specifically as
a comparison to the kind of oppression
that Richard was trying
to escape in the south.
So this is caught up in a moment of
patriotism where American freedom is being
held up very much as the ideal.
That thing that we fight for
when we go to Europe to fight.
And so to have Richard present this
picture of America that doesn't ring the
changes of that patriotism comes
to be a problem in her mind.
Now,
when black boy was published,
there was a war bond advertisement
on the back cover of the book.
It really was just even as a physical
object all bound up with the politics of
its moment.
Richard's response to this,
we just have two seconds. I
want to show it to you. It's um,
I love these, these pieces. Um,
because you can just see
him struggling on the page.
Sorry.
This is his first attempt at writing
back to her. See all the scribbles.
This was hard for him. There are two
other drafts. If you go and look at them,
it's quite interesting.
He's trying extremely
hard to make an answer.
And what he ends up doing is bringing
that knowledge that he built up in
Chicago.
The knowledge that he gets from reading
economics and sociology and Marxism.
He gives an analysis of
industrial capitalism.
That's the kind of framework he uses to
try get her to understand what it would
mean to be a negro in the south.
How isolated he was culturally,
how impossible it is to see something
like an ideal America of freedom and
justice from that subject position.
In the end,
the compromises that he notes.
Um,
several writers including
Dreiser and Sherwood Anderson,
and I just want to have you compare the
catalog of writers on four 13 that he
mentions there.
Dreiser Edgar Lee Masters,
HL Mencken Anderson and Lewis.
All American writers compare that with
the catalog that he gives of his reading
on to 49 and you'll see
what's being alive. Right.
Okay.
This is the top of two 49.
Um,
so certainly we have Sinclair
Lewis Sherwood Anderson,
but then we have Dostoyevsky George
more Gusta flow bear Maupassant Tolstoy,
Frank Harris, Mark Twain, Thomas Hardy,
Arnold Bennett, Stephen Crane's doe law,
Norris Gorky,
Bergson Ibsen Belzec.
You get the point.
This is a very cosmopolitan reading list.
What Canfield Fisher asks him to
present is a totally nationalistic one.
My point in some,
what I want you to take away from this
is to see how an account of a life is
struggling against
forces outside of itself.
Publishing forces the forces of politics,
of war,
of an editor,
how a writer is struggling to make his
account faithful to his own artistic
vision,
his own social vision.
Against those forces and how
those forces have an impact.
Tries. He might have an impact on what
the text looks like when we hold it in our
hands.
Black boy,
we're American.
Hunger is a dramatic example and
thanks to the buying of key and to the
scholarship that's been done on it by the
editor who brought this whole text out
in the 1990s.
Arnold Rampersad thanks to that work.
We get to see it up close. We get to
see what that back and forth looks like.
We'll have another version of this one.
We think about Lolita,
which in your edition has a,
uh,
an essay at the end called
on and novel entitled Lolita.
That's only there because someone
tried to censor that book.
It's another example of how the world
comes to impinge on and change our reading
experience.
It's something that we will come
back to and explore more in the,
in the next class.